[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
Miami en Florida a continuación
hablaremos de la polémica ley anti
inmigrante impulsada por ron de santis
el gobernador de este estado que
criminaliza con hasta 15 años de prisión
a quienes transporten indocumentados o
impone multas de 1000 dólares diarios a
quienes contraten gente sin papeles la
legislación ha sembrado el temor entre
los migrantes que incluso ya piensan en
abandonar el estado en este programa
también veremos como las organizaciones
se están movilizando para presionar a
los legisladores el paraíso de Florida
puede convertirse en un verdadero
infierno para los indocumentados
[Música]
desde el 1 de Julio rige la ley
sb17-18 que ha firmado el gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis la
medida pretende castigar duramente la
emigración irregular sabemos que si esta
ley pasa Va a criminalizar a las
personas que están ahorita tienen
familiares indocumentados tienen
personas que están aquí que quieren y
esta ley es muy indestructiva contra
nuestra nuestra nuestras comunidades la
ley invalida las tarjetas de
identificación y licencias de manejar de
otros estados en algunos sitios como
Nueva York no se requiere un estatus
migratorio para conseguir un carrete de
conducir a partir de ahora solo será
válida una identificación de Florida
requiere a los hospitales a reportar al
gobierno Estatal los indocumentados que
atienden y contempla un presupuesto de
12 millones de dólares para enviar
indocumentados a otros estados del país
además esta legislación obliga a las
empresas de más de 25 empleados a
utilizar el sistema
y verify para certificar el estado
migratorio de los trabajadores en caso
de contratar a personas sin papeles
estas compañías se enfrentarían a multas
de mil dólares diarios yo creo que
para todos pues ha sido un golpe duro
porque pues tenemos la mayoría muchos
Tenemos muchos años aquí tenemos
nuestros hijos aquí hemos vivido una
vida prácticamente aquí en este estado
de la Florida y yo creo que hemos
ayudado a construirlo también verdad que
criminaliza a los inmigrantes y los
inmigrantes contribuimos a la comunidad
los inmigrantes vinimos a trabajar somos
gente honestas y trabajadora y el punto
que ha causado más indignación es el que
prohíbe transportar indocumentados a
Florida de hacerlo los conductores
podrían ser acusados de tráfico humano
se establecen penas de cinco años de
prisión y multas de 5.000 dólares sin
indocumentado es mayor de edad pero de
15 años de prisión y multas de 15 mil
dólares sin el vehículo hay menores
Baltasar es de Guatemala hace dos años
emprendió una peligrosa travesía hasta
que logró cruzar ilegalmente la frontera
de Estados Unidos llegó al sur de la
Florida donde se ha establecido trabaja
en el campo pero como muchos de los
indocumentados tiene miedo a ser grabado
y a ser víctima de represalias en su
puesto de trabajo ahora está pensando en
abandonar el estado por la ley del
gobernador recuerda que sólo vino en
busca de una vida mejor porque no está
poniendo cargas sobre nosotros que no
somos ningún delincuente para para que
nos ponen esta ley nosotros que lo que
venimos es a trabajar a levantar este
país según el instituto de políticas
migratorias cerca del 4% de la población
de Florida es indocumentada la mayoría
trabaja en sectores del campo de la
construcción y del hogar además otro
informe del instituto de políticas de
Florida revela que si los inmigrantes la
economía del Estado perdería 12.600
millones de dólares disminuiría un
1,1%. los migrantes sin papeles
reivindican su papel aseguran que hacen
el trabajo que otros con papeles no
quieren hacer y Recuerden que sin su
aportación el país no avanzaría por eso
en las últimas semanas varias
organizaciones hicieron un llamado al
día sin inmigrantes para visibilizar la
importancia de esta comunidad en Estados
Unidos no salir a la no ir a las
escuelas no llevar a nuestros niños no
ir a trabajar no salir para no consumir
nada y para que se vea en la economía
que que sí que hace falta la comunidad
la verdad Yo también me estoy haciendo
para no voy a trabajar y no voy a
comprar nada no voy a comprar nada
apoyando ahora sí que a todos los que
están en lo mismo porque realmente pues
lo nosotros lo que solamente queremos
trabajar no estamos haciendo nada malo
en este país no le hacemos daño a nadie
el gobernador de Florida sin embargo se
defiende de sus políticas asegura que lo
está haciendo bajo el amparo legal y que
solo Busca acabar con el tráfico humano
debemos fortalecer aún más nuestras
leyes contra la inmigración ilegal
mejorando la verificación de empleo
aumentando las penas por el tráfico de
personas y desincentivando aún más la
migración ilegal al estado de Florida
Florida no es un estado santuario y de
tenemos el estado de derecho
pero lo cierto es que aún hay muchas
dudas sobre cómo se implementará esta
ley los inmigrantes sin papeles están
desconcertados incluso los abogados
especializados en temas migratorios
advierten que hay muchas lagunas es una
ley tan dura que se hace muy difícil
aplicarla no sabemos cómo al final del
día qué tan estricto van a ser los
policías qué tan estricto van a querer
aplicar esta ley las organizaciones
prominentes denuncian que todo es una
estrategia política de desantis de Cara
a las próximas elecciones de 2024 pero
ya han avisado que van a interponer una
demanda ante esta ley sin embargo no
pueden hacerlo hasta que esta medida que
castiga los indocumentados entre en
vigor el 1 de julio y confían en que la
justicia les de la razón y se derogue la
legislación hasta aquí enlace
Norteamérica Gracias por sintonizarnos y
recuerde que para ver de nuevo Este
programa puede visitar nuestro sitio web
France 24.com
hasta la próxima